well would you believe it dear old chuck
todd got right to the heart of this
issue this morning when he asked
secretary of state anthony blinken this
about russia and ukraine
let me ask this question
in your assessment why did putin why is
he do escalating with ukraine now why
didn't he do this under the previous
administration
who wasn't as supportive of nato
hmm let's think perhaps because in the
real world not the fake pr driven world
of washington pundits and all most
democrat politicians and it seems all
the senior members of the biden regime
in the real world what you do is more
important than what you say what the
previous administration president trump
did
is send arms to ukraine reversing the
obama-biden position
what trump did
is actually strengthen nato by shaming
them into spending more on defense and
most importantly of all given that
russia is as someone once observed
basically a gas station with nuclear
weapons president trump massively
increased our leverage against russia by
expanding our domestic energy production
and making us a net exporter for the
first time in nearly 70 years on top of
that trump put sanctions on the pipeline
that was a lifeline for russia's economy
germany's nordstrom 2. in a word trump
projected strength
putin took note he didn't try anything
on when trump was there neither did
china's dictator she or iran or little
rocket man
now let's look at what biden has
projected
on the actual substance actions not
words it's been a slow motion surrender
to vladimir putin on his first day biden
attacked our energy industry by
cancelling the keystone pipeline within
weeks he lifted trump's sanctions on
putin's pipeline evidence taking office
biden has waged war on american energy
to pander to his extremist climate
zealots even though trump's expansion of
natural gas helped reduce our carbon
emissions
even more ludicrously by cutting
domestic energy biden had to beg opec to
pump more oil now
biden's talking tough on putin
we're ready to impose severe sanctions
on russia if it further invades ukraine
oh severe sanctions can someone please
tell his own administration because the
day before biden said that his own
energy regulators were imposing severe
sanctions on us
a massive new clamp down on liquefied
natural gas pipelines and export
terminals we have huge amounts of
natural gas sitting underground in
appalachia that we could export to
europe so they don't have to rely on
putin's gas and biden just blocked it
you think putin didn't notice
it's not just on energy the same day as
biden was threatening severe sanctions
on russia his own deputy national
security adviser was asked if that would
include kicking russia out of the
international financial transaction
system swift here's what he said
it's probably not going to be the case
that you'll see swift in the initial
rollout package we have other severe
measures we can take that our allies and
partners are ready to take in lockstep
with us and that don't have the same
spillover effects
spillover effect yeah that's economics
jargon for things that have unintended
consequences elsewhere so what message
does that send to putin we'll shut you
out of the world economy except we won't
because that might hurt us
the biden people are patting themselves
on the back for their brilliant new
strategy of trying to beat putin at his
own game of information warfare by
disclosing his moves in advance
because today's democrats treat
everything as pr because for them virtue
signaling is more important than reality
they seem to think that they can somehow
beat putin with media relations head
fake him into backing down these people
are just not serious the great geniuses
of governance and foreign policy jake
sullivan ron claimed biden himself with
all his years of experience yeah years
of being wrong as bob gates memorably
put it he has been wrong on nearly every
major foreign policy and national
security issue over the past four
decades and bob gates worked alongside
biden in a barber's cabinet
putin can smell biden's weakness a mile
off biden claims he's rallied the allies
so they're all going to stand up to
putin oh really
guess what the germans pledged to help
defend ukraine 5 000 helmets not helmuts
not 5 000 german troops five thousand
helmets
two weeks ago finally understanding the
strategic importance of the nordstrom
pipeline biden hosted german chancellor
olaf shot in the white house and bragged
about persuading the germans to shut
nordstrom down if putin made a move
if russia invades uh
that means tanks or troops crossing the
uh the border of ukraine
again then uh
there will be uh we there will be no
longer a north stream too we will bring
an end to it the notion that
nordstrom t would go north stream two
would go forward
with an invasion by the russians is just
not going to happen
he's really struggling there but at that
exact same press conference standing
next to biden schultz refused to even
say the words nordstream he was asked
directly repeatedly and he wouldn't say
it great job there joe rallying the
allies and by the way let's just recall
that a certain president raised the
nordstrom issue years ago
so we're supposed to protect you against
russia but they're paying billions of
dollars to russia and i think that's
very inappropriate and the former
chancellor of germany is the head of the
pipeline company that's supplying the
gas
ultimately germany will have almost 70
percent
of their country
controlled by
russia with natural gas so you tell me
is that appropriate i mean i've been
complaining about this
from the time i got in it should have
never been allowed to have happened
exactly now
biden and all the establishment geniuses
want to shut down nordstrom they say but
when trump said it it was all oh my god
how embarrassing how undiplomatic what a
joke they all are putin can see they're
a joke he can see how biden has made
america weaker
not just the self-sabotage on energy but
weakening our defenses cutting our
military
the humiliating surrender to the taliban
and our catastrophic bungled exit from
afghanistan none of this helps america
it hurts america
and here's what else hurts america the
idea
that random dictators can just invade
countries on a whim or to seize
resources or because of some twisted
historical obsession as we're seeing
with putin in ukraine and xi jinping
with taiwan that is not a world we
should want to live in it does matter
the countries play by the rules of
civilized society people look to america
to uphold the values of freedom and
opportunity and self-determination
that's why so many people admire and
love america
and as a new citizen i can testify to
that personally as you know my parents
fled from communism in hungary but most
of the family stayed behind when i was a
kid i heard this phrase all the time to
describe a horde of people your neck
minta zorosok it means they're coming
like the russians and in 1956 the
russians did come crushing the people's
revolution in hungary the west did
nothing in my family along with millions
of other hungarians suffered another 30
odd years of communism i'm not saying we
should go and get bogged down in yet
another war of course not
but the choice is not between sending
americans to die in some distant land
while our own land is under threat
moreover and doing nothing
there's another way a better way and
guess who figured it out yes the person
that the foreign policy geniuses who got
us into the endless wars dismisses an
incompetent maniac trump was the first
president in decades not to get america
involved in a new war like reagan he
understood the idea of peace through
strength
and like reagan he understood that a
strong country a strong military is
built on a strong economy
watch this from a conversation i had
with president trump in 2019
i want to invade if i have to
economically we've created a much
stronger country economically than when
i took it over we have tremendous power
economically if i can solve things
economically that's the way i want
america first does not mean america
alone and it does not mean america stays
at home it means america leads
economically scientifically militarily
america first america number one america
leads
when you have a strong president who
gets this and projects this they don't
need to engage in ludicrous pr games and
information warfare again watch
president trump respond when i asked him
on another occasion about xi jinping and
taiwan
if china and it looks like they're
getting more and more belligerent tries
to either invade taiwan or effectively
take control of it and its important
industries
would you let them get away with it i
think it's an inappropriate place to
talk about it but china knows what i'm
going to do
china knows
xi jinping knew that trump wouldn't
stand for any aggression putin knew that
trump wouldn't stand for any aggression
iran north korea they all knew
and the world was safer america was
safer as a result sadly that is not the
situation we face today today we have a
president who is undermining all of
america's advantages because he's too
weak too feeble to stand up to the far
left activists who now run his party
as a result instead of peace through
strength we could be facing war through
weakness
tell us what you think it's steve hilton
x and at next drive fnc and please share
this message when we post it